questa è l'unica immagine di questo tipo
che vedrete relativa alle rovine in
questa presentazione perché questo era
quello che le rovine anno nei secoli
passati rappresentato questo era un
paesaggio del settecento in quest'epoca
le rovine soprattutto i capricci di
rovine ovvero mettere insieme creare dei
set con rovine prese da posti diversi e
quindi creare questa questa atmosfera
bucolica felice di grande bellezza in
qualche modo perché questo le veline
evocavano però c'è un però che queste
rovine erano le rovine storiche cioè le
resta i resti quello che rimane di di
mondi diversi di società diverse di
tecnologie diverse
questo vuole dire che nessuno di noi si
vedrebbe dentro a questi edifici
nell'epoca in cui erano attivi come
nessuno di noi probabilmente si vedrebbe
all'interno di un castello medievale né
nella società del castello medievale e
questa è la grossa differenza tra le
rovine storiche le rovine del
contemporaneo perché le rovine storiche
ci rimandano a un capitolo del libro
della storia che sta molte pagine
indietro mentre invece le rovine del
contemporaneo fanno parte dello stesso
capitolo cioè noi facciamo parte del
loro capitolo anche noi dovremmo essere
i fruitori degli incompiuti che abbiamo
visto prima noi dovremmo essere le
persone che usano quel tipo di edifici
che non sono stati terminati sono stati
abbandonati e cioè tra usano le stesse
tecnologie facciamo parte della stessa
della stessa epoca e per questo ci
ispirano generalmente ispirano imputo un
altro tipo di sensibilità di sentimento
guardate vi racconto come è nato tutto
che c'è un piccolo aneddoto il primo
giorno di un laboratorio di tesi
magistrale mi sono presentato a degli
studenti che probabilmente volevano
qualcosa di un obiettivo preciso è
qualcosa di molto solido proponendo agli
di condividere i miei grossi dubbi e di
andare alla ricerca di un progetto che
non si sapeva dove sarebbe andato
infatti i miei quello che proponeva di
condividere la cercare di capire perché
io fossi particolarmente attratto dalle
rovine in termini di incompiuti
abbandoni disastri e del futuro quando
veniva rappresentato soprattutto un
futuro passato mi piacciono molto le
immagini dei film di fantascienza degli
anni 50 quelli in bianco e nero noi
interessa molto il futuro immaginato
oggi quindi un futuro che può essere
veramente immaginare quello che vogliamo
noi interessava moltissimo capire perché
come un tipo di futuro vecchio potesse
essersi sgretolato nel tempo quindi in
realtà qua dietro c'erano c'era c'era un
po l'idea del sublime il sublime che è
la stessa cosa che ispirava i vedutisti
del settecento non è solamente legato al
bello vuole dire andare
esplorare andare oltre il limite è
arrivare a togliere il fiato
mai iniziato lo toglie anche un pugno
nello stomaco e questo è il tipo di
termine che abbiamo usato per con col
quale abbiamo chiamato tutti i casi che
abbiamo incontrato di rovinare
contemporaneo perché gli studenti
ovviamente bravissimi si sono
appassionati e abbiamo esplorato in
tutto il mondo i casi del genere sono
fantastici e la maggior parte di questi
pugni nello stomaco trovato deriva da un
vuoto perché una mancanza una mancanza
che può essere a vari livelli
le rovine si creano perché viene a
mancare perché vengono a mancare le
persone perché viene a mancare il motivo
per cui le persone stavano ling e per
disastri naturali per problemi economici
in realtà quindi è un vuoto di sicuro ma
un vuoto denso perché agisce su tanti
livelli sono sempre situazioni molto
complesse che è difficile
comprendere completamente e anche
codificare infatti pur se io sono molto
lontano da quello che ha e fedele con la
psicanalisi su una fase di freud che
trovo particolarmente pragmatica in
questo caso nell'impossibilità di
poterci vedere chiaro almeno vediamo
bene le oscurità e questo abbiamo fatto
abbiamo analizzato dei casi in tutto il
mondo e ne abbiamo fatto una selezione
l'abbiamo fatto anche un libro appunto
quello di cui si parlava arti flop è un
libro che del quale spot sfoglio con voi
alcune alcuni alcune immagini e il
racconto perché per esempio questo è un
isola del giappone ashram circa 5.000
abitanti era legata delle attività
estrattive quasi da un giorno all'altro
queste attività da un periodo molto
breve queste attività estrattive sono
venute a mancare e i 5.000 abitanti sono
stati portati da un'altra parte e quindi
l'isola è rimasta abbandonata e io oggi
si presenta così come aneddoto vi dico
che c'è stata girata anche qualche scena
di uno 007 ma la cosa interessante è che
tra l'altro se vedete qua oggi è meta di
un turismo
adesso non essere abituati forse
immaginare che i turisti vadano a capri
e ischia e non in un posto del genere
però si sta diffondendo anche un turismo
legato a questo tipo di particolare
perversione alla quale mi associo
assolutamente questo è un altro caso la
torre davide è il terzo grattacielo del
venezuela 45 piani incompiuto
prima era così ovvero l'ossatura in
cemento armato non aveva elettricità non
aveva
l'impianto idrico era rimasto solo per
problemi finanziari legali eccetera si
presentava in questo stato
ci hanno pensato loro
da una fame dalle favelas si sono mossi
e hanno occupato tamponandolo
risolvendolo e risolvendolo per loro
quindi portando l'elettricità portando
l'acqua portando i servizi tamponando se
lo è organizzata mettendo le pareti dove
si arriva si sono organizzati la più
alta favela verticale le persone che non
avevano casa e quindi questo è stato
anche un ha menzionato a una biennale di
architettura è un'opera molto
interessante perché questa struttura che
era abbandonata è stata riutilizzata e
ha creato praticamente un villaggio
verticale del quale poi i cittadini sono
anche molto orgogliosi che curano gli
interni per quanto nelle loro
possibilità per l'appunto ne curano gli
interni vanno avanti lo portano i
servizi cioè se un altro caso
interessante di come una rovina possa
evolvere ecco questo è un caso invece
queste cao lunghe è un
un quartiere di hong kong
si presentava così è stato per un
periodo il posto più densamente popolato
del pianeta perché era una zona franca
dentro hong kong che già di per sé
rispetto alla cina non era insomma era
già abbastanza e quindi essendo una zona
franca dove potevano essere svolte cose
che da svolte vendute cose che da altre
parti erano illegali
molti volevano vivere qui e quindi in
realtà si era creato un enorme mattone
pieno di persone queste erano le vie di
questo posto quindi era si scavavano
all'interno per poter passare ma non si
vedeva il cielo per vedere il cielo i
bambini e le persone doveva andare sui
tetti
questo è un esempio che non ce l'ha
fatta l'hanno dovuto abbattere in questo
caso adesso non esiste più questa è una
delle è una delle possibilità che questi
tipi di questi esempi queste questioni
vengano risolte abbattendole questo
invece è un aneddoto
al di là del limite scusate fatto così
postazione antiaerea al largo delle
coste inglesi talmente al largo da
essere fuori dalle acque territoriali
un simpatico mattacchione lo si
autonomina principe e lo nomina
principato
siamo alla terza generazione di principi
di sealand che è una piattaforma di 500
metri tra cemento armato che si sta
corrodendo e
screpola ndaw e lamiere arrugginite è un
altro modo di vivere un un edificio in
rovina diciamo poi esistono cose di
questo genere che sono città cinesi
costruite a su capite chiaramente un
quartiere francese riprodotto con tanto
di torre eiffel una città fatta per due
milioni di persone abitata da 100 150
mila quindi sostanzialmente un enorme
palco vuoto lo usano usano un po
quest'area per fare per i matrimoni
periodo per fare le foto
ma in angola città vicino alla capitale
costruita interamente da zero di nuovo
vuota anche in questo caso la città in
africa ma la società cinese
ecco sono realtà di fronte alle quali è
difficile esprimere un giudizio prendere
una posizione o pensare a una soluzione
però sono realtà che stanno emergendo
nel 30 sono moltissime
ce ne sono davvero tante e
questi sono ancora volendo da un punto
di vista antropologico più interessante
sono i parchi divertimenti abbandonati
che giappone dreamland luoghi dove
dovevano esserci schiamazzi bambini le
coppie sulla sulla ruota e invece sono
posti dove non c'è più niente il cemento
si crepa la natura se ne sta
riappropriando e sono posti desolati
sono tutti i futuri brillanti falliti
quindi in realtà sono presenti molto
fragili come i vecchi pugili o cose del
genere
di fronte a dei presenti molto fragili
di solito il progetto ha sempre qualcosa
da proporre o da dire per lo meno questo
dovrebbe essere uno degli obiettivi noi
abbiamo di fronte a questa lettura
difficilissima ci siamo dati due linee
due possibilità quelle di leggerle come
una seconda natura quindi come qualcosa
sul quale poter intervenire senza
giudicare che anche una delle linee mi
sembra dell'incompiuto siciliano è
quella di prendere logiche nuove qui
cito un amico franco bolelli che dice
sempre detto che le le soluzioni non
vanno cercate nello stesso cassetto dei
problemi
in effetti questo succede a volte che se
qualcosa non è andato bene come parco
bisogna inventarsi qualcos'altro perché
sicuramente non lo si può riproporre per
lo stesso motivo per cui è fallito
quindi noi abbiamo fatto una prova con
la torre galfa che un edificio che sta a
milano di fronte al pirelli una
bellissima architettura di fine anni 50
che è stato ed è tuttora è stato di
abbandono è stata oggetto di un
interessante esperimento sperimentazione
di macao appunto che
illuminata sotto i riflettori però di
fatto al momento è ancora una un luogo
abbandonato ed è un gran peccato
e di fronte in un luogo centrale agli
studenti abbiamo proposto di immaginare
una tipologia nuova di far diventare di
immaginare che questo spazio diventasse
un luogo pubblico e non fosse più
risolto con le categorie
dell'architettura ma come un grande
giardino verticale parco urbano
verticale quindi tutte le funzioni
dall'agricoltura alla atp nuovi di
biblioteche a sport venissero messe una
sull'altra e diventasse un parco
pubblico verticale quindi con una logica
completamente diversa per inciso questa
in altro questa in alto era una zona
franca
in realtà un grande giardino botanico di
sostanze illegali con un coffee shop
sopra
io non so se queste sono le logiche se
questa una soluzione efficace però
quello che qui credo veramente che col
quale concludo è che non è tanto
internet non è tanto importante
discutere età il bello e il brutto
quanto cercare fare in modo che queste
cose non impediscano la produzione di
nuove idee
grazie mille